as a rule all objects in space are
located enormous distances away from
each other
the fact that huge bodies like stars may
at some point collide
is mind-boggling but the universe
takes pride in stunning us and hardly
everything we can see in a telescope may
be given a conventional explanation
here is my camelo pardolis one of the
brightest stars located within our
cluster
we used to consider it a single object
for quite a while
however spanish scientists have recently
found out
that it is in fact two huge stars in the
process of merging
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
this binary system has been on the
astronomical map for several decades
and all the while has been thought of as
just one super bright star
my camelo pardolis or my cam for short
is 13 000 light years away from the
earth
it used to be classified as a variable
star
the object aroused interest only as late
as in 2014
when a group of spanish scientists was
able to define mycam
as a binary star system the discovery
was made
thanks to a 2.2 meter telescope in the
calar alto observatory
both stars boast a comparatively big
mass
and are drawn quite close together with
their router atmospheres almost touching
one of them is 38 masses of our sun
and the mass of its companion is 32
masses of our sun
the radius of each measures 700 those of
our planet
just to compare it's six times the
radius of our sun
as for the age of these objects they're
comparatively young
and cannot be over two million years old
m y kam may well be called one of the
most
massive binary star systems known to
science
both objects of the system are hot blue
o type stars
their rotation speed may reach up to one
million kilometers per hour
with the surface temperature of each of
them as high as 40
000 kelvins the orbital period around
their common center
is about 28 hours which means that both
giants complete a full orbit around each
other
in a bit over a day just to compare
our sun completes one full rotation in
26 days
my cam is also quite bright which makes
it visible even through a common
telescope
the star's orbit is a rather narrow one
which is why they're alternately
eclipsed
practically every day this explains
constant changes in their luminosity
before this fact became known scientists
used to be confused about the properties
of this stellar system
the existence of my cam doesn't seem to
be that incredible
considering the fact that most celestial
bodies in the milky
way were formed in big stellar systems
whose objects were also
variable and eclipsing stars this means
that these objects overall luminosity
may vary from time to time
m y cam can be called one of the best
known stellar systems of the kind
in fact it seems to have been originally
formed like this
and has always looked the way we can
observe it today
since the components are in such close
proximity
sooner or later they are bound to
collide and then merge into one
enormous star whose mass may well reach
as much as
60 sun masses thanks to theoretical
modeling
it is assumed that when stars merge it
is a quick procedure accompanied by a
big bang
with incredible amounts of energy
released as a result
if this happens with my cam astronomers
will be able to observe this
demonstration
confirming the theory that supermassive
stars are formed
when two less massive objects merge
to date science has not yet witnessed a
merging process of this kind
the possibility of our sons taking part
in a similar process
is quite negligible according to today's
estimates
a collision of the main star of our
system with another star
may take place once every 10 to the
power of 28 years
but even with such a minuscule chance of
this collision
our earth would be seriously affected
where it to take place somewhere close
by space
standards if it were to happen within a
hundred light-years from us
our blue planet would be completely
devastated
however at this point there isn't a
single star cluster within that range
so far we have only been able to record
the result of two neutron stars
collision
in theory this process should result in
the formation of a neutron star with an
even bigger mass
or else it should cause the formation of
a black hole
when merging neutron stars are capable
of generating a magnetic field
billions of times more powerful than
that of the earth
this process may be accompanied by a
gamma ray flare
that is the most powerful energy
emission in the universe known to us
i mentioned it at some point in other
videos
however in spite of the tremendous scale
of this phenomenon
astronomers have never been able to
directly observe the process
of merging stars one of these events
the grb-150101
gamma-ray flare was detected only in
the event made it possible to draw
connection with gravity waves
detected back in 2015
gravity waves are also a result of two
neutron stars merging
it looks like something similar awaits
some white cam as well
and if a planetary system were in its
vicinity
it would be a far less serene place to
be around in comparison with our planet
the enormous mass of my cam is
indicative of its short life
which leads us to assume that
intelligent organisms would simply not
have had enough time to develop
on its hypothetical planets besides
as the stellar system grows older both
its components
increase in their dimensions this
process
brings my cam ever closer to its
inevitable destiny of becoming a
supermassive stellar giant
and then an even heavier neutron star or
else a black hole
the amy camp system is also peculiar for
the fact that it is located in a region
of the universe
rather densely filled with stars regions
like that are sometimes referred to
as globular star clusters
star mergers are rather common in areas
of this kind
since the number of stars there is by
far greater than in our system's
proximity
according to the latest estimates star
collisions in globular star clusters
occur approximately once every ten
thousand years
unlike my cam objects like our sun
are sail drifters in a galaxy with only
a planetary system for company
however such celestial objects are not
that common
in the universe some like single stars
in the milky way
account only for a measly two percent
most stars are part of multiple systems
for example triple star systems are the
most
common accounting for about 75
of all observable stars
most of them have to struggle with the
gravity force of their companions
throughout their lifetime this
interaction
in its turn leads to the formation of
even larger stellar systems
most of the supermassive stars known
today
may at one point have been part of
systems with at least
one companion of an identical mass
thanks to frequent eclipses occurring in
multiple star systems
scientists are able to investigate the
celestial objects
in more detail in the case of my cam for
instance
astrophysicists detected a wide range of
specters of light
emanating from it they went on to use
the doppler effect
thus measuring the star's orbital speeds
with this knowledge it was safe to
maintain that my cam
is an exceptional object in space
in the future this stellar system will
enable us to confirm some hypotheses
as to the formation of massive stars in
our galaxy
when celestial objects like that are
discovered
we grow ever stronger in our belief that
our universe
is an amazing place concealing an
unimaginably large number of as yet
unknown phenomena each of them poses a
hurdle for science
but once it is negotiated our
civilization continues to develop
and expand its knowledge about space
surrounding us
we will soon get even more information
about my camelo pardolis
as an object with such exciting
properties can't but attract attention
of scientists
all over the world there is no knowing
what features of star formation we will
be aware of at that time
but it is safe enough to say even now
that these remote gigantic stars
will never cease to amaze us
[Music]
you